I'm Jamal Adams and I'm Judy Smith
Schuster and we're here at the BMW
Performance Centre in thermal California
here to test out the new BMW 3-series
this is our time to auto cross force
we're gonna put you guys on the clock
see who can get the fastest time the
rules are simple if any portion of your
car is outside of the designated stop
box that's two seconds added to your
time if you hit a cone it's worth two
seconds of penalty added to your time
for every cone that you hit we're gonna
throw it down you guys ready already
hey listen Vegas is not too far go place
your bet hey we'll see I'm very
confident I just got my license probably
bought like six months ago so I'm not
worried about nothing big red baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys I got your times right here
both of you did great but it only comes
down to one winner coming in first a
hold three seconds faster was Jamal
we got the first-place trophy I just
want us out with egg BMW for it might be
out to have these opportunities smoke
that me want to take my pants in the
mail you guys want to take a hot lap you
want to take a lap around the track with
me see how I do it all right when I get
shot
what's up have you guys ever done
anything like this before flying a roll
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]